we've got new information this morning
reportedly shows Facebook gave its
corporate partners extensive access to
your personal data for years and never
told anyone a report in The New York
Times says Facebook made data sharing
deals with dozens of the world's other
tech giant's internal documents appear
to show that Facebook allowed companies
to access information like users private
messages and the names of virtually all
of their Facebook friends
it's the latest privacy scandal to hit
the social media giant Tony de coppola
is here with the potential impact for
it's 2.2 billion users Tony good morning
good morning the time says it reviewed
hundreds of pages of Facebook documents
and interviewed about 50 former
employees and its corporate partners The
Times allegedly found Facebook collects
more information on people than almost
any other private corporation in history
at a congressional hearing in April CEO
Mark Zuckerberg insisted the data of
facebook's more than two billion users
is safe yes or no is Facebook limiting
the amount or type of data Facebook
itself collects or uses congressman yes
we limit a lot of the data that we
collect and use but according to a new
report in The New York Times for years
Facebook struck deals to share users
personal data with more than a hundred
and fifty companies including Netflix
Spotify and Amazon among the allegations
in the report Facebook allowed Spotify
Netflix and the Royal Bank of Canada to
read write and delete users private
messages Amazon was able to obtain users
names and contact information through
their friends and Microsoft's Bing was
able to see the names of virtually all
Facebook users friends without consent
we have a basic responsibility to
protect people's data and if we can't do
that then we don't deserve to have the
opportunity to serve people privacy
issues security breaches and the
distribution of fake news has plagued
Facebook for months the scandals have
forced Zuckerberg and chief operating
officer Sheryl Sandberg to publicly
apologize we know that we did not do a
good enough job protecting people's data
and I'm really sorry for that and marks
really sorry for that
The Times reports Facebook's partners
were able to seek the data of hundreds
of millions of people a month the time
says the deals were all active in 2017
and some were still in effect this year
in a statement to CBS News Facebook said
its partners don't get to ignore
people's privacy settings and it's wrong
to suggest that they do adding we know
we've got work to do to regain people's
trust and that's where we've been
focused for most of 2018 now this could
go beyond bad public relations for
Facebook and here's why a 2011
settlement agreement with the Federal
Trade Commission requires Facebook to
obtain consumers consent before sharing
their information a facebook
spokesperson told The Times most of its
partnerships did not require this
because it quote considered partners
extensions of itself pretty clever
Facebook says it found no evidence that
any of those partners abused users data
and speaking of the partners in a
statement to CBS News Netflix said at no
time did we access people's private
messages on Facebook or asked for the
ability to do so
a spokesperson for mark ourselves Bing
said throughout our engagement with
Facebook we requested all user we
respected all user preferences Spotify
said they were unaware of the broad
powers Facebook had granted them the
bottom line is Facebook has been saying
we don't sell users data but this
article alleges that they have been
trading it well Mark Zuckerberg has also
assured lawmakers that people have
complete control over everything that
they share on Facebook and that
statement appears to be not true
you know one of the media organizations
given access to Facebook users data was
the New York Times that publishes report
yeah interesting gear from them on that
subject but it was important that you
brought at the point of whether or not
they violated that FTC agreement that
could that raises a lot of Jeopardy for
the company that's going to echo in the
weeks and months ahead yep
thank you Tony to cope oh you're very
busy is it okay to tell America you and
your lovely wife Katy tur reported
another network mrs. Cotner
couple are expecting a baby we are
indeed I mean yes it's okay she already
went public with it yeah
privacy settings have pretty much
lowered on that question Congrats Tony
very happy new year yeah this is
wonderful news for us